- Talent is the great equalizer
of all the things
that people are scared of.
Don't worry America
everything will be fine.
Talent still matters.
(upbeat music)
- You were born
in the Soviet Union.
- [Gary] I was.
- [Rebecca] How much
do you think that shaped
who you are now?
- An enormous amount.
I think being born in a
Communist country as a purebred
capitalist and then having the
great fortune to be able to come
to America and then to
be really not wealthy and
not have stuff as a kid.
To be emotional that my parents
bought me two "Star Wars"
figures when I was six and
knowing that was
an enormous deal.
To know that when I wanted stuff
my mom was very quick to tell me
go buy it yourself
and go earn it.
It absolutely, absolutely,
absolutely shaped me.
And the other thing, you know,
especially in the political
climate we all live in now,
I don't think people understand
how amazing America is.
It makes me
enormously optimistic,
very positive and those are very
important traits if you're gonna
be insane and actually
go after entrepreneurship.
- How did you do
this whole thing?
You built it from the ground up.
- I've been producing
content online for 10 years.
Early YouTube when I started the
wine show for my prior career.
(upbeat jazz music)
And about two,
three years ago,
I wasn't doing
the wine show any more.
I was once in a blue
moon putting out some content
but it was building up.
I'm like there's an
opportunity for me to talk.
There's new thoughts
in my mind and we started
a show called
The #AskGaryVee Show.
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
And then vlogging started taking
off on YouTube more and more and
so kind of the marriage of
YouTube first person vlogging
and reality TV became the
concept behind DailyVee which we
started earlier this year and
it's become a very substantial
part of the brand building
of myself and my agency.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
- [Gary] I think it's really
smart to create a
North Star and reverse engineer.
Seven years ago, after making
a lot of money on investments,
decided to build an agency.
Full service,
media buying, creative,
strategy,
video production, all of it.
Not just one like the rest of
the agency world and I was gonna
build it for myself.
And so I was
gonna take a step back,
eat crap 'cause you have to
have clients and that stinks.
Especially when you've
already made your money.
- How do you do that?
'Cause you're
very outspoken person.
- [Gary] I do it
'cause I eat crap.
'Cause they're the boss.
My dad has a Russian saying:
whoever pays for the
music gets to pick it.
- When you were
in those first years,
you took advantage of YouTube
very early on as you said.
- Yes.
- Was there ever a fear of well
if I'm not creating the video
content maybe I'm
focusing on the wrong thing.
- I've only had one substantial
advantage against the market
which is I just
worked 13 and 14
and 15 hours a day.
If you're competing against
people that are working seven
and eight and really five and
six when he count in lunch and a
couple of YouTube
videos and a phone call or two,
I was never worried about that.
I always had enough time
to be what I am which is the
CEO of a $100 million
dollar revenue agency and,
you know especially with the
infrastructure around now 'cause
I'm a five person team which
really a modern-day
production company.
- What's been the hardest lesson
for you to learn in your life?
- [Gary] That
I can't do everything.
- What are things you would
love to be doing
that you're not doing?
- Nothing. I'm in
full control my life.
If there's
something I want to do,
then I can go do it.
We make our beds
so I sleep in it.
- [Rebecca] What do you think
about all the evangelists today
who talk about
you need more sleep,
you need to work less?
- All of it is very personal.
I don't need society telling
me how to do work-life balance.
me how to raise my children.
That being said, I'm a
huge advocate of sleep.
I'm all-in for six, seven.
I mean I always try to get
six or seven hours of sleep.
That's plenty.
I'm just more worried about what
you're doing while you're awake.
- Right. Not wasting your time.
- [Gary] 100%.
- One of your main things--
- If you're complaining,
now by the way,
this is only if you complain.
If you don't complain,
you can do anything you want.
This is for the people saying,
"I wish I had," or
"You got lucky," or
"This is unfair,"
for those people if you're on
four softball teams and watch
entire seasons of stuff on
Netflix, you can't complain.
- Do you watch Netflix?
- I don't.
I consume the reactions
of my community
to my content and
that's why I over index
with my community
'cause I've allocated
my leisure time or my escapism--
- To reading your comments?
- and providing value and I hope
through example and content
I'm able to inspire that but
I think practicality is grossly
underrated and
for all my sizzle,
I'm obsessed with the steak.
- Because in the world of advice
giving there is tons of sizzle
and not a lot of steak.
Does that frustrate you?
- I don't think I'm in the
advice giving business and
I understand why
everybody would think that.
I think I'm in the documenting
what I'm up to business.
A quick little
walk to the Garden.
Haven't done this yet
so I'm excited about that.
Oh, DRock, look at that.
They're doing the, what is that?
- [DRock] What
are you pointing at?
- [Rebecca] What do
you think it is then
that attract people
to you?
- [Gary] I think they understand
genuinely that I have no
interest in getting
anything out of them.
The only thing I want from them
is their attention and in return
I'm willing to give
them everything I got.
Oh!
I think when
I look at my contemporaries
AKA other people that are
in the advice giving business,
there's always a
punchline at the end.
Sign up for my course,
come to my event,
travel to my destination thing.
I don't want anything from them.
I just want the thing that
my mom gave so much to me
that I still need it which
is I want their attention.
- What do you think of the
influencers and the desire among
so many people to
become influencers now?
- I'll separate them.
What do I think about
the actual influencers?
That they're the one of the
two or three best
deals in advertising.
What do I think of everybody's
aspiration to be one?
Makes a whole lot of sense.
Sounds like a lot of fun to make
$300,000 a year taking selfies
with products on Instagram.
- [Rebecca] But?
- But 99% of the people
watching aren't talented enough
to actually create an audience.
- What do you
think because, you know,
everything about who you are--
- By the way,
everybody should try.
- Really?
- Of course.
Let me rephrase everybody
who wants to should try.
- [Rebecca] This is why I think,
this is why I question
your thoughts on that.
- Go ahead.
- Because every--
- I'm excited this
is where it gets fun.
Go ahead.
- Everything you stand for
authenticity and being true to
what you are, who you are.
- [Gary] Yes.
- There are so many
influencers now who,
not all them but a lot of
them, in order to make that
$300,000 a year you have
to endorse tons of products,
some of which you probably
don't actually stand for.
- Yeah and so what will happen
over time is that audience will
start to walk away from that
person if they're not creating
enough value in return.
I think it's a value exchange.
I also think that we're
educating our clients of just
'cause she has 4 million
followers if when she says buy
this, if they don't believe her
you're gonna waste money and
I think as the maturity of
the market understands that
authentic execution's
gonna really matter.
- That's what you
built your business on.
- [Gary] Listen, I have never
done a sponsorship deal on my
content in 10 years and
I got offered in 2006 to put
bottled water on the
table of Wine Library TV.
- Why didn't you do it then?
- Because I knew I was gonna
make money in a different way
and I didn't want
to lose the exchange.
Once you ask for something,
you've lost leverage.
- What was the lowest point
for you so far along the way?
- Fourth through 12th grade.
- Why?
- Because I wasn't built to
go through that horse crap of a
education machine that America
is for kids that are
purebred entrepreneurs.
- What were some of
the experiences you had?
- Teachers telling me that
I would never succeed in life
while I was making $3,000 a
weekend selling baseball cards
and making more money
than they were making.
For all my bravado and
ego, I got really lucky.
My parents gave
me the right DNA.
I have a lot of humility.
I didn't need to
prove it to those teachers.
I didn't need to razz them.
I didn't need to stick it to my
friends' parents who didn't want
their kids hanging out with
me because I'd be a bad school
influence and I wasn't
gonna be a winner.
I grew up in the era
in the '80s and '90s when
education was
the only way to win.
You were gonna be successful
if you went to
Harvard and then won.
There was no conversation
around entrepreneurship.
When I was a kid, entrepreneur
meant that you were a loser.
- What is the worst advice
you've received along the way?
- Almost everything
anybody's ever told me.
Advice is bad
unless it's contextual and
you really dig deep.
I give very little advice to
my employees until I start
to really get to know them.
And so, most people like to
give advice without context.
The best advice only comes from
the people closest to you and
the ones that actually have
your best interest
in mind, not theirs.
That means almost nobody because
that means everybody's on the
outside and a lot of
times the people on the inside.
I mean mommy and daddy are
giving you advice in
their best interest, not yours.
- So how do you differentiate?
- I just don't
listen to anybody.
- Has that come back to hurt
you in any way do you think?
- I'm sure but
I'll take where I'm at.
And I mean in
life, not in business.
It's so funny how your flaws can
end up becoming your strengths.
My enormous need for attention
has made me give so much more to
my audience than I ask in return
because I know that
will give more attention.
My sense of self has made me
obsess over how many people are
gonna show up to my funeral
which then makes me want to be
nice to everybody
along the way because--
- [Rebecca] What do
you want them to
say about you at your funeral?
- [Gary] That he was the
greatest human
being that ever lived.
- [Rebecca] The greatest
human being that ever lived?
- [Gary] Yep.
- That didn't take my advice.
- Yeah, I mean I don't
think anybody's gonna be there,
like at my funeral nobody's
gonna be there that ever tried
to give me advice.
Because there's only,
there's nobody left.
It's unbelievable how
visceral I am to advice.
Nobody even attempts it anymore.
- For people out
there who are feeling stuck,
they've been trying over and
over again to
get what they want.
It's not working out,
what do they do?
- Something severe like get a
divorce or stop talking to your
dad or quit your job.
I mean it.
Let me tell you why, stop
talking to your dad sounds like
terrible advice until you
start realizing the thing that
I've come across over the last
year or two which is most people
don't do things because they're
scared to fail in
front of somebody.
And then you start unwinding
and you realize my God they're
scared to fail in front of
somebody who's within their
inner circle,
who they love the most,
who's holding them down.
Poison is bad.
It's bad.
- When is the last
time you were afraid?
- I'm afraid everyday.
- What are you afraid of?
- The health and
well-being of my family.
And I mean for real.
I'm actually more scared
than almost anybody I know.
I've never been
scared in business.
- You're neurotic?
- [Gary] I'm just genuinely
concerned about the health and
well-being of my family.
- What are you afraid of?
- Them dying.
I love them very, very much.
I'm being very serious with you.
Work? Never.
- Usually I ask people for their
best piece of advice to people
but since you're not in the
advice giving business--
- Yes.
- for people who see what you've
built and they wish to emulate
it in some way, what do they do?
- They have to punt almost
everything besides their family
and work 24/7/365 hard as hell.
(house music)